that it's not so difficult to win someone
in order to betray others.
Even some of the top dissidents in East Germany
collaborated with the Stasi,
as for instance Ibrahim Böhme.
In 1989, he was the leader of the peaceful revolution
and he nearly became the first freely elected Prime Minister of the GDR
until it came out that he was an informant.
The net of spies was really broad.
In nearly every institution,
even in the churches or in West Germany,
there were many of them.
I remember telling a leading Stasi officer,
"If you had sent an informant to me,
I would surely have recognized him."
His answer was,
"We didn't send anyone.
We took those who were around you."
And in fact, two of my best friends
reported about me to the Stasi.
Not only in my case, informers were very close.
For example, Vera Lengsfeld, another leading dissident,
in her case it was her husband who spied on her.
A famous writer was betrayed by his brother.
This reminds me of the novel "1984" by George Orwell,
where the only apparently trustable person
was an informer.
But why did the Stasi collect all this information
in its archives?
The main purpose was to control the society.
In nearly every speech, the Stasi minister
gave the order to find out who is who,
which meant who thinks what.
He didn't want to wait until somebody
tried to act against the regime.
He wanted to know in advance
what people were thinking and planning.
The East Germans knew, of course,
that they were surrounded by informers,
in a totalitarian regime that created mistrust
and a state of widespread fear,
the most important tools to oppress people
in any dictatorship.
That's why not many East Germans tried
to fight against the Communist regime.
If yes, the Stasi often used a method
which was really diabolic.
It was called Zersetzung,
and it's described in another guideline.
The word is difficult to translate because it means
originally "biodegradation."
But actually, it's a quite accurate description.
The goal was to destroy secretly
the self-confidence of people,
for example by damaging their reputation,
by organizing failures in their work,
and by destroying their personal relationships.
Considering this, East Germany was a very modern dictatorship.
The Stasi didn't try to arrest every dissident.
It preferred to paralyze them,
and it could do so because
it had access to so much personal information
and to so many institutions.
Detaining someone was used only
as a last resort.
For this, the Stasi owned 17 remand prisons,
one in every district.
Here, the Stasi also developed
quite modern methods of detention.
Normally, the interrogation officer
didn't torture the prisoner.
Instead, he used a sophisticated system
of psychological pressure
in which strict isolation was central.
Nearly no prisoner resisted
without giving a testimony.
If you have the occasion,
do visit the former Stasi prison in Berlin
and attend a guided tour with a former political prisoner
who will explain to you how this worked.
One more question needs to be answered:
If the Stasi were so well organized,
why did the Communist regime collapse?
First, in 1989, the leadership in East Germany
was uncertain what to do against
the growing protest of people.
It was especially confused
because in the mother country of socialism,
the Soviet Union,
a more liberal policy took place.
In addition, the regime was dependent
on the loans from the West.
Therefore, no order to crash down the uprising
was given to the Stasi.
Secondly, in the Communist ideology,
there's no place for criticism.
Instead, the leadership stuck to the belief
that socialism is a perfect system,
and the Stasi had to confirm that, of course.
The consequence was
that despite all the information,
the regime couldn't analyze its real problems,
and therefore it couldn't solve them.
In the end, the Stasi died
because of the structures
that it was charged with protecting.
The ending of the Stasi
was something tragic,
because these officers
were kept busy during the peaceful revolution
with only one thing:
to destroy the documents
they had produced during decades.
Fortunately,
they had been stopped by human rights activists.
That's why today we can use the files
to get a better understanding
of how a surveillance state functions.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Bruno Giussani: Thank you. Thank you very much.
So Hubertus, I want to ask you a couple of questions
because I have here Der Spiegel from last week.
"Mein Nachbar NSA." My neighbor, the NSA.
And you just told us about my neighbor,
the spies and the informant from East Germany.
So there is a direct link between these two stories
or there isn't?
What's your reaction as a historian when you see this?
Hubertus Knabe: I think there are
several aspects to mention.
At first, I think there's a difference
of why you are collecting this data.
Are you doing that for protecting your people
against terrorist attacks,
or are you doing that for oppressing your people?
So that makes a fundamental difference.
But on the other hand,
also in a democracy, these instruments can be abused,
and that is something where we really have
to be aware to stop that,
and that also the intelligence services
are respecting the rules we have.
The third point, probably,
we really can be happy that we live in a democracy,
because you can be sure that Russia and China
are doing the same,
but nobody speaks about that
because nobody could do that.
(Applause)
BG: When the story came out first,
last July, last year,
you filed a criminal complaint
with a German tribunal. Why?
HK: Yeah, I did so because of the second point I mentioned,
that I think especially in a democracy,
the rules are for everybody.
They are made for everybody, so it's not allowed
that any institution doesn't respect the rules.
In the criminal code of Germany, it's written
that it's not allowed to tap somebody
without the permission of the judge.
Fortunately, it's written in the criminal code of Germany,
so if it's not respected, then I think
an investigation is necessary,
and it took a very long time that
the public prosecutor of Germany started this,
and he started it only in the case of Angela Merkel,
and not in the case of all the other people living in Germany.
BG: That doesn't surprise me because —
(Applause) —
because of the story you told.
Seen from the outside, I live outside of Germany,
and I expected the Germans to react
much more strongly, immediately.
And instead, the reaction really came only
when Chancellor Merkel was revealed
as being wiretapped. Why so?
HK: I take it as a good sign,
because people feel secure in this democracy.
They aren't afraid that they will be arrested,
and if you leave this hall after the conference,
nobody has to be afraid that the secret police
is standing out and is arresting you.
So that's a good sign, I think.
People are not really scared, as they could be.
But of course, I think, the institutions
are responsible to stop illegal actions
in Germany or wherever they happen.
BG: A personal question, and this is the last one.
There has been a debate in Germany about
granting asylum to Edward Snowden.
Would you be in favor or against?
HK: Oh, that's a difficult question,
but if you ask me,
and if I answer honestly,
I would give him the asylum,
because I think it was really brave what he did,
and he destroyed his whole life
and his family and everything.
So I think, for these people, we should do something,
and especially if you see the German history,
where so many people had to escape
and they asked for asylum in other countries
and they didn't get it,
so it would be a good sign to give him asylum.
(Applause)
BG: Hubertus, thank you very much.